This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百真人。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难历程》，我是你们最喜欢的心理治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的生活经历，进行一些在其他地方真不敢聊的走心对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人带着一副铠甲生活？这向世界暗示，你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须得这么做，听听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难历程》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让人生下了双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾多次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我当时震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷情网》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷情网》播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的方法。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终就会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索2%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总说
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode where we break down this psychology of your 20s. Something that I think a lot of us struggle with, deal with, have on our minds is feeling kind of stagnant in the moment that
相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听播客《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，我们将在这里剖析你二十岁的心理学。我认为我们许多人都面临、纠结、思考的一个问题，就是在我们当前所处的
we're in and in our current life chapter or life season I guess and that is something I've personally been thinking about a lot the further I get into my 20s the more I'm kind of hungering for a life change and I thought why not bring on one of my favorite podcasts one of my favorite people actually who has helped me and given me advice even if she doesn't know it through her show love happiness and success to share some of her wisdom with us so well well Welcome, Dr. Lisa Marie-Bobby. Thank you for coming on the show. You are too kind, and I'm flattered and honored that you listen to the podcast, and it's so wonderful to know that it's been helpful for you.
这个时刻以及我们目前的人生阶段或生活季节中，感觉到一种停滞不前，我想这也是我随着年龄增长，越发深入二十岁时，个人一直在思考的一个问题，我对生活变革的渴望越来越强烈，所以我想为什么不请来我最喜欢的播客之一、也是我最喜欢的人之一呢？她通过她的节目《爱、幸福与成功》帮助过我，并给了我建议（哪怕她自己并不知道），来和我们分享她的一些智慧。所以，欢迎莉萨·玛丽-博比博士。谢谢你来到节目中。你太客气了，对于你听这个播客，我感到非常荣幸和受宠若惊，知道它对你有所帮助真是太美妙了。
I mean, that's fantastic. That's why I make them, so mission accomplished. Yeah, well, it's so interesting. I was saying this to you before, people always ask me, like, what do you listen to? And I'm like, I listen to this show. I listen to your show. I feel like it's so interesting because I'm sure a lot of people listen to this as their source of wisdom and their source of advice. But I think also like the advice giver also needs,
我的意思是，这太棒了。这就是我制作播客的初衷，所以任务圆满完成。是的，这太有趣了。我之前对你说过，人们总是问我，比如：“你平时都听些什么？”我说：“我就听这个节目。我听你的节目。”我觉得这很有意思，因为我相信很多人把这当作获取智慧和建议的来源。但我认为，给别人提供建议的人其实也需要，
you know, the advice of others and also needs like the knowledge of others as well. So thank you so much for the work you do. Do you want to explain a little bit more about who you are, your approach, your maybe journey to where you are now? Yeah, no, I'm happy to. So, so yeah, Lisa Marie-Bobby, gosh, my journey starting in my 20s, trying to figure out what the heck I was going to do in the world. And I went through a period in my 20s where I felt very lost and unclear as well. And actually, we could talk more about this. So my pivotal moment in my 20s was 9-11. So the terrible, you know, terrorist attacks. My cousin actually was killed in, he, he, he was. He, he, he, worked at one of the World Trade Center buildings. It was awful. But it was this crisis where I was
你知道，别人的建议，也需要别人的知识。所以非常感谢你所做的工作。你想不想多解释一下你是谁、你的方法、以及你是如何走到今天这一步的历程？好的，没问题，我很乐意。所以，莉萨·玛丽-博比，天哪，我的历程从二十岁开始，当时我试图弄清楚我到底要在世界上做什么。在二十岁的那段时期，我也感到非常迷茫和困惑。实际上，我们可以多聊聊这个。所以我在二十岁时的转折点是911事件。也就是那场可怕的恐怖袭击。我的表亲实际上在那场袭击中丧生了，他在世贸中心的其中一栋大楼工作。那太可怕了。但正是这场危机让我
like, what am I doing with my life? And it really led me to do a lot of personal soul searching. And it was right after that that I decided to go back to school to become a therapist, which I began in my 20s. I since became a marriage and family therapist and then did a doctoral degree, became a licensed psychologist, pursued coaching as a career path, which has been really exciting for me. And so I founded a private practice. It's called Growing Self-Counseling and Coaching. And we have, you know, 50-plus therapists running around here these days and also started the Love Happiness and Success Podcast, kind of as a hobby because I love, you know, talking about personal growth and self-development. And one of the values that I connected with when I was in my 20s related, you know, with everything
开始思考：我到底在用生命做什么？这确实促使我进行了大量的自我灵魂搜索。也正是在那之后，我决定重返校园成为一名心理治疗师，那是在我二十多岁的时候开始的。后来我成了一名婚姻和家庭治疗师，接着攻读了博士学位，成为了一名持证心理学家，并将教练作为职业发展道路，这对我来说非常激动人心。因此我创立了一家私人诊所。它叫做“成长自我咨询与教练”（Growing Self-Counseling and Coaching）。如今我们这里有50多位治疗师在忙碌，我也创办了《爱、幸福与成功播客》，起初算是一个业余爱好，因为我喜欢谈论个人成长和自我发展。而在我二十多岁经历这一切时，我所契合的价值观之一，就是
that I went through, realized how important it was for me personally to be of service to other people. And so that's why I started doing my podcast, just to like share things and advice and knowledge and put it out into the world. And that, I mean, so when you were talking about the fact that you enjoy the show and that you've benefited from it, like, that's why I do this. And I can't tell you how happy that just made me here. Oh, my goodness. Well, I'm so glad that I could, I don't know. I don't know if it's encouragement, but just to share the love, I guess it's so nice when people say that to me. So I'm sure that, yeah, it's good to pass that on to everybody who you also benefit.
意识到对我个人而言，为他人服务是多么重要。所以这就是我开始做播客的原因，只是为了分享一些事情、建议和知识，并把它们传递到世界上。所以，当你谈到你喜欢这个节目并且从中受益时，这就是我做这件事的原因。我无法形容听到这话让我有多高兴。哦，天哪。好吧，我很高兴我能，我不知道这算不算鼓励，但就是分享这份爱吧，当人们对我说这些话时，感觉真是太好了。所以我也确信，把这份正能量传递给每一个让你受益的人，也是一件很好的事。
from. I want to go back to that kind of pivotal moment because I feel like that is firstly so tragic. I'm so sorry that that happened but I think it's also something that a lot of people in their 20s might relate to having some major life change, some maybe not a tragedy but a major life event that kind of puts them onto a completely different path and in other senses, it can also be so gradual, right? Like this gradual loss of self, this gradual loss of belonging, this gradual sense of like, I just feel really stuck in my life. So why do you think that, why do you think we get to those points where we realize that we need a change? Is it just because of those things, those kind of extessential moments that make us question our purpose or is there
我想回到那个转折点，因为我觉得首先这太悲惨了。发生那样的事我很遗憾，但我也觉得这也是许多二十岁的人可能会感同身受的经历，比如经历一些重大的生活变故，也许不是悲剧，而是一个重大生活事件，把他们带上了一条完全不同的道路；从另一个意义上说，它也可能是渐进的，对吧？比如这种逐渐的自我丧失，逐渐的归属感丧失，这种逐渐的感觉就像是——我觉得我的生活真的卡住了。所以你认为为什么，为什么我们会走到这些意识到我们需要改变的节点？仅仅是因为那些迫使我们质疑人生目的的生死时刻吗？还是有
something deeper or something more gradual that happens there? Yeah. Well, I'll tell you a secret, actually, that I don't think is talked about enough in our culture, is that the reason we all grow is not despite the challenges and the hard times that we go through. It's really because of them. I'm a big believer in that we really kind of need to make contact with our dark emotions. And because that's like where a lot of our inner wisdom really is. And it's only when you go through something challenging if it's a crisis, like a building blowing up in a terrorist attack. That would be one example. But also, it really is a crisis when you get to this place in your life and you're like, I don't know who I am or what I want or what I'm doing.
更深层次的东西，或者说有什么更渐进的事情在发生？是的。其实我来告诉你一个秘密，我觉得我们在文化中对这个讨论得还不够，那就是我们之所以成长，并不是因为我们克服了经历的挑战和困难时期。恰恰相反，正是因为经历了这些。我坚信，我们确实需要去触碰我们的黑暗情绪。因为那是我们很多内在智慧真正所在的地方。只有当你经历了一些具有挑战性的事情时——比如大楼在恐怖袭击中炸毁这样的危机，这就是一个例子。但同样，当你走到人生这个阶段，觉得“我不知道我是谁，我想要什么，我在做什么”时，这确实也是一场危机。
Like to really like recognize that and sit with those feelings, it brings up a lot of pain. And that too can be its own kind of crisis that can catalyze a lot of really important growth work and personal development. And then I think people that are just kind of happy to be here and bopping along and feeling good, they don't get to do that. They don't have a reason to do that. And so I think the shift comes and really like appreciating the hard times for what they are, which are these fantastic opportunities that often go unrecognized. You know, we try to make it go away rather than understanding them for the gifts they are. Does that make sense? It makes so much sense.
真正去认可并直面这些感受，会带来很多痛苦。而这本身也可以是一种危机，能够催生出大量非常重要的成长工作和个人发展。然后我认为那些只是高兴地生活、随波逐流、感觉良好的那些人，他们就无法经历这些。他们没有理由去这么做。因此我认为这种转变来自于真正欣赏困难时期的价值——它们是那些经常未被认知的绝佳机遇。你知道，我们试图让它们消失，而不是去理解它们带来的礼物。这说得通吗？这太说得通了。
It reminds me of this quote. my mom always says to me, which is you can either choose to be comfortable or you can choose to grow. And so it's in those moments of, yeah, in those moments of the greatest discomfort that we find ourselves changing the most for the better. But I still think that it's really difficult when you're, when you get to that point and you're like, it's interesting what you said. There are some people who are happy to just kind of go with the flow and happy to go along with the status quo. I'm sure that the people listening to this are perhaps not those people. and are perhaps facing a lot of confusion. How do you navigate that? How do you navigate feeling
这让我想起了一句名言。我妈妈总是对我说，那就是你可以选择舒适，或者你可以选择成长。所以正是在那些，是的，正是在那些极其不舒服的时刻，我们发现自己为了变得更好而改变得最多。但我仍然认为，当你到了那个点，觉得——你刚才说得很有意思。有些人很高兴随波逐流，满足于现状。我确信听这个节目的人可能不是那种人，
simultaneously quite stuck and also wanting more for yourself? Like what are some of the steps to move into that next chapter of your life when you realize that perhaps you are unhappy? Yeah, that's a really good question. And it's a multi-layered answer. because I want to be honest with you and your listeners. And so to not give some trite-like thing. I mean, the truth really is that, first of all, it requires a period of exploration in order to understand what is at the core of the happiness and dissatisfaction.
他们或许正面临着许多困惑。你如何应对这种情况？你如何同时应对那种感到停滞不前，却又渴望为自己争取更多的心态？当你意识到自己可能并不快乐时，迈向人生下一篇章的步骤有哪些？是的，这是一个非常好的问题。这是一个多层次的回答。因为我想对你和你的听众保持坦诚。
And that in itself can be difficult to wrap your arms around sometimes. You know, like the sort of nebulous dissatisfaction bit being. able to get clarity and articulate what it's attached to. And so like that's one of the reasons why it can be helpful either to talk to a therapist or also like just to do some journaling is to get under your own hood and like what is going on? Is it something that I'm doing that I actually don't like that much? Is it something that I'm not doing? Like am I missing something that I wish was here?
而不是给出一些陈词滥调。事实确实是，首先，它需要一段探索期，以便理解快乐与不满足的核心到底是什么。而这本身有时就很难让人理清头绪。你知道，那种朦胧的不满感，要能够获得清晰的认识并说出它究竟跟什么有关，是很难的。所以这也是为什么要么找心理治疗师聊聊，要么写写日记会很有帮助的原因，这样才能深入自我内心去看看究竟发生了什么？是我正在做某件其实我没那么喜欢的事吗？还是我有什么事没做？比如我是不是错过了某种我希望拥有的东西？
But that's really the first chapter, is just beginning to get clarity around who you are, what you want, and like naming the pain points. Once that's clear, then you can begin to develop a vision of a life that had the changes that were in alignment with how you imagine. You know, things would be for you to feel happier. but that growth can also go in a different direction too that I'm happy to share more about if it would be helpful. The other thing, there are two pieces of this. One piece is that sometimes the reason we feel dissatisfied is that we're living a life that is not really in alignment with who we are, what our
但那真的只是第一章，仅仅是开始弄清楚你是谁、你想要什么，并为痛点命名。一旦这些清晰了，你就可以开始构想这样一种生活：它的改变与你想象中如何能让自己感到更快乐的愿景相一致。但这种成长也可以走向另一个方向，如果对你有帮助的话我很乐意分享更多。还有另外一件事，这里面包含两部分。一部分是，有时我们感到不满的原因，是因为我们过着的生活与我们究竟是谁、我们的
values are, what we want. And it's important to understand that. so that you can make a plan to change your life circumstances so that it's more congruent with who you are and what you really want. That's kind of door number one. The other thing that is also true is that many times it's not our life circumstances at all that are leading to our feeling unhappy or dissatisfied. It's more about how we are functioning on the inside so that if we don't do that internal work, It doesn't matter how differently your life changes in terms of the day to day, because you're still going to feel the same way you do right now. I honestly really relate to that.
价值观是什么、我们想要什么并不真正契合。理解这一点很重要，这样你才能制定计划改变你的生活环境，使其与你是谁以及你真正想要的东西更加一致。这可以说是第一扇门。同样真实的另一件事是，很多时候，导致我们感到不快乐或不满意的根本不是我们的生活环境，而是更多地取决于我们的内在运作方式——如果我们不去做那项内在工作，
I feel like I've had points where I felt that if I just change something about my circumstances, everything else will fall into place. I moved to Sydney with that belief where I was like, all right, the source of all my problems is this town that I'm living in. and if I just change my environment, I'm going to change everything else that comes with it. And you realize that your problems do not leave you if you think that you're leaving them behind. Like they are so much more internal than they are external. Can you explain that a little bit more in terms of how to manage that?
不管你的日常生活发生什么样的改变，你最终的感觉还是会和现在一模一样。老实说，我真的很有同感。我觉得我曾有过这样的时刻：我觉得只要我改变环境中的某样东西，其他一切都会水到渠成。我怀着这种信念搬到了悉尼，当时我想：“好啦，我所有问题的根源就是我住的这个小镇，如果我只是改变了环境，我就会改变随之而来的所有其他事情。”然后你就会发现，如果你以为自己能把问题抛在脑后，它们是不会离开你的。相比于外在，它们其实要内在得多。你能就如何管理这一点再多解释一点吗？
Because I feel like the first option there to realize that you're dissatisfied because it doesn't match the vision of your life, engage in some of that exploration and find something perhaps more purposeful. That, although it is still difficult, feels like the simpler path. But that second path of being like, actually there is something internally that is making you realize that you are dissatisfied and unfulfilled and creating all of these other like secondary mental consequences. That sounds like such a maze.
因为我觉得第一个选项——意识到你的不满是因为它不符合你的人生愿景，然后进行一些探索并找到某种更有目标感的东西——尽管这依然很困难，但感觉是一条更简单的道路。但第二条路径，也就是认识到：“其实是内部的某种东西让你意识到自己是不满意的、空虚的，并引发了所有这些其他诸如此类的次生心理后果，”听起来就像是一个巨大的迷宫。
Yeah, it absolutely is. And it's so easy for all of us to get tricked into believing that. You know, I'll be happy when I have a different career. I live in a different place. Or I'll be in a relationship or, you know, meet some health goal, right? And this was actually researched pretty extensively. Martin Seligman, he was a past president of APA, and he's one of the thought leaders around the School of Psychology called Positive Psychology. And he identified this a long time ago, and he called it the hedonic treadmill. And so what it is is this belief that, you know, we all pursue these goals or these changes or these circumstances getting the career or the house or a new car or whatever.
是的，绝对是这样。我们所有人都太容易被这种想法欺骗了。你知道，“等我有了不同的职业我就会快乐”、“我住在不同的地方”、“我会谈恋爱”或者“实现某种健康目标”，对吧？其实这已经被广泛研究过了。马丁·塞利格曼（Martin Seligman），他是美国心理学会（APA）的前任主席，也是心理学中积极心理学流派的思想领袖之一。他很久以前就指出了这一点，并称之为“享乐适应水车”（the hedonic treadmill）。所以它的意思是，我们都在追求这些目标、改变或环境——比如获得职业、房子、新车或其他什么。
And then arrive at whatever, you know, the top of that mountain was and discover that we feel pretty much the same way that we did before we achieved whatever those goals were. And now it's absolutely valuable to design a life that you want to live in, right? And pursue circumstances and life experiences that you feel good about. Nobody's mad at that. But the work that we're talking about now is really getting under the hood to understand why your sort of emotional thermostat is set at this kind of constant level, no matter what. That work requires understanding a number of different things, how you're talking.
然后当你到达那座山的顶峰时，却发现我们的感觉和实现这些目标之前几乎一模一样。现在，设计一种你想在其中生活的生活，并追求那些让你感觉良好的环境和生活体验，这绝对是有价值的。没有人会反对这一点。但我们现在谈论的工作，是真正深入内心去了解为什么你的情绪“恒温器”不管怎样都设置在这个固定的水平上。这项工作需要理解许多不同的事情，你如何对自己
talking to yourself has a lot to do with it, like the kind of relationship that you're having with yourself, your inner dialogue can be a big piece of that. Also, I think managing your expectations for who you are and like what life is supposed to feel like is a big piece of that. And I think, you know, especially on the theme of your podcast. I mean, the psychology of your 20s, I think that a lot of us, and I certainly had this when I was in my 20s, have these, ideas about the way things are supposed to be or like how other people feel like happier, better than I do. And I think it takes a while to arrive at the fact that a lot of life is pretty, you know, we have ups and downs and to feel kind of average or neutral a lot of the time is
说话与此有很大关系，比如你和自己的关系如何，你的内心独白可能是其中的很大一部分。此外，我认为管理你对自己的期望以及生活应该是什么感觉，也是其中的一个重要部分。而且我认为，特别是结合你的播客主题。我是说，关于你二十岁的心理学，我认为我们很多人——我在二十岁时也确实如此——对事情“应该”是什么样子，或者其他人是否比我感觉更快乐、更好，都有着这种成见。而且我认为要接受这样一个事实需要一段时间：生活的大部分其实都挺，你知道的，我们有起有落，而且很多时候感觉相当普通或中性，其实是
actually normal. And when people are thinking that they should be feeling differently than life is actually like can make them worry that something is wrong. You see this with people in long-term relationships or dating or, you know, in a career. And I think there's a lot of actually long-term satisfaction and inner peace that comes from embracing the fact that all of life is kind of a mixed bag and that peak experiences can happen and we can have moments of joy. But a lot of life is just fairly neutral. So then the work becomes how to find gratitude and meeting and appreciation and satisfaction in the things that are really pretty ordinary because the anxiety that like something is wrong is one of the things that will reliably make you feel dissatisfied no matter what.
很正常的。当人们认为自己的感受应该不同于实际生活时，就会担心是不是出了什么问题。你在处于长期恋爱关系、约会或职业生涯中的人身上都能看到这一点。而且我认为，接受生活整体上是个大杂烩，巅峰体验会发生，我们也会有快乐的时刻，但生活的大部分其实相当平淡——从这种接受中会产生很多长期的满足感和内心平静。因此，接下来的工作就变成了如何在那些非常平凡的事情中找到感激、意义、欣赏和满足，因为那种“有什么不对劲”的焦虑，无论如何都是最可靠地让你感到不满的原因之一。
Yeah. And that social comparison as well, I guess. Like I think that is the biggest thief of joy of people in our 20s and I hear it all the time we have this constant source of comparison being social media where I can look online and see someone's impeccable highlight
是的。我想还有社交比较。我认为这是我们二十多岁的人最大的快乐小偷，我经常听到这种说法：我们有一个持续的比较来源——社交媒体，在那里我可以在网上看到别人无可挑剔的高光时刻集锦，
reel of all of the best moments of their life and the blanks, those days that they don't feel great and not filled in and sometimes I know that I'm guilty of doing this as well like I was telling you I've been quite ill these
展示他们生活中所有的最好时刻，而那些空白、他们感觉不好的日子并没有被填满。有时我知道自己也对此感到内疚——正如我刚才对你说的，我这几周一直病得很厉害，我的相册或生活里其实没什么大事发生。比如，我没有去参加盛大的活动。我没有在庆祝职业里程碑。我没有在开派对或做类似的事情。我只是处于一种有点低谷、有点停滞的阶段。我没有把这些发到网上。我没有把事情坦诚的一面展现给大家。而我觉得，你刚才所说的简直太对了：看看你的
last few weeks, there's nothing really going on in my camera role or my life right now. Like, I'm not going to big events. I'm not celebrating career milestones. I'm not partying or anything like that. I'm just in like a bit of a rut stage, like a bit of a flag stage. And I'm not posting about that online. I'm not giving people the candid side of things. And I think that that is so spot on what you just said of look at your. of that false belief that everyone else is happier than us, that something should be a certain way, is really robbing us of our ability to be deeply satisfied in what we have.
这种虚假的信念——即其他人比我们更快乐、某些事情应该以某种特定方式呈现——真的在剥夺我们对现有事物深度满足的能力。
Yeah, absolutely. I completely agree because, you know, there's so much image management and the things that go out into the world versus the reality of what day-to-day life is actually like and how, you know, just maddening and frustrating it could, Be, so example, right? If you look at my social media stuff, there's reels and like the business and the podcast and giving people advice, like I know what I'm doing. And just this morning, trying to order pizzas online. I have people coming over later today for Halloween. Couldn't find my bank card
是的，完全同意。因为你知道，对外展现的形象管理与日常生活实际是什么样的、以及事情会变得多么令人抓狂和沮丧之间，存在着巨大的差异。比如说，对吧？如果你看我的社交媒体内容，上面有短视频、业务、播客以及给别人提建议，看起来我好像什么都懂。然而就在今天早上，我正试图在网上订披萨。今天晚些时候我要办万圣节派对，结果我到处都找不到银行卡。
anywhere. And then when I did try to use the bank card, it's like, you know, I had to move money to the debit account. It's like just all these tiny little frustrations. And then like I hadn't put the laundry away so I couldn't find the sweater that I wanted to wear. It's just one thing after another, right? And these are all like little minor irritations, but I was like, ah! And none of that goes out into the world. And so even for me, like, I've been working on this stuff for 20 years. And I'm thinking, why am I getting so stressed out about all this stuff?
然后当我终于试着使用银行卡时，系统提示我需要把钱转到借记卡账户里。就像所有这些微小的小挫折。然后我还没把洗好的衣服收起来，所以找不到我想穿的那件毛衣。简直是一波未平一波又起，对吧？这些都是一些小小的烦恼，但我当时就想：“啊！”而所有这些都不会被发到世界上。所以即使对我来说，你知道的，我研究这些东西已经20年了。我还在想：“我为什么会为所有这些事情感到如此压力山大？”
And like, my house is a wreck. I can't find anything. And just blah, blah, blah, blah. And really, like, feeling so annoyed. And then had to, like, talk myself down, use all these skills, like, shift my thoughts to a better feeling place so that I could go into work, you know, and have a reasonably nice day. But it's so easy to go down that rabbit hole of like, what is wrong with me? And especially when it comes to relationships, oh my goodness, like I can't tell you how many clients I've worked with that,
而且我的房子一团糟。我什么也找不到。等等等等。真的觉得非常恼火。然后不得不自我开导，运用所有这些技能，比如把思绪转换到一个感觉更好的地方，这样我才能去上班，（你知道的）度过一个还算不错的一天。但人太容易陷入那种“我到底怎么了”的思维黑洞了。特别是当谈到恋爱关系时，天哪——我简直无法数清我有多少个客户，
you know, they've been single, they want a partner, they get into a relationship, you know, they meet a nice person who is annoying and disappointing in their own ways and just, like this, you know, everybody's a mixed bag. Like, this is, you're going to have some of these experiences in every relationship, but there's some, you know, perfectionistic ideal in their mind that makes them feel so badly about the relationship or the life that they have. It's hard. Oh, I can imagine that so hard.
他们一直是单身，想要一个伴侣，然后进入了一段恋爱关系，（你知道的）他们遇到一个好人，但在各自的方面又很烦人、很让人失望，就像这样，你知道的，每个人都是一个大杂烩。就像这样，你在每段关系中都会有一些这样的经历，但他们心中有一种完美主义的理想，这让他们对自己的关系或生活感到非常糟糕。这太难了。哦，我可以想象那有多难。
It's something I've actually encountered where I've, I'm in a long-term relationship now, but when we first started dating, I was like, why does this feel boring? like this and it felt so safe that I was like this feels boring everyone's told me that there needs to be this like insane intimacy and passion and chemistry chemistry and I was like yeah and I was like there is chemistry and there's compatibility but this person is not like making me run on a treadmill for their affection that's what I feel like is exciting I feel like I've gone off on a tangent because I'm just like laughing up your words here but it's probably my fault I'm known for going off on random tangents. So welcome to my world. So am I. I feel like that we're match made in heaven.
其实我也遇到过这种情况，我现在处于一段长期的恋爱关系中，但当我们刚开始约会时，我曾想：“为什么这感觉这么无聊？”这种感觉太安全了，以至于我觉得“这好无聊啊，每个人都告诉我，应该要有那种疯狂的亲密感、激情和化学反应。”然后我想：“对啊，确实有化学反应，也有契合度，但这个人并没有让我为了他的好感而在跑步机上疯狂奔跑。”我觉得这才是令人兴奋的。我觉得我扯远了，因为我只是在这里被你的话逗笑了，但这可能怪我，我一向以容易扯到各种随机话题而闻名。所以，欢迎来到我的世界。我也是。我觉得我们简直是天作之合。
But I feel like to bring it back to that idea of starting that next chapter in your life, perhaps the first way to do that is to appreciate, to gain a more realistic view of what life actually is. And that's not to say that life isn't going to be full of surprises and full of excitement and full of amazing moments, but that that is not going to be happening all of the time. Like changing something external about your life isn't going to suddenly remove what is the deepest satisfaction from self-comparison or social comparison
但我觉得，回到开启人生下一篇章这个想法上，也许这样做的第一步是去欣赏并对生活到底是什么有一个更现实的看法。这并不是说生活不会充满惊喜、充满兴奋、充满精彩的时刻，而是说这些时刻不会每时每刻都在发生。改变你生活的外部因素并不会突然消除来自自我比较或社交比较的最深层不满意，
or from unrealistic expectations about how you should be feeling on a day to day. So I feel like that's our first collective tip on moving to the next chapter. Well, and even to add to that is to, in that work of wanting a new chapter to get under our hoods, doing some journaling, talking to a counselor or a coach around what are my themes. What have been the patterns and the repeating experiences that I've had in all of these different chapters that I've had so far, because that can give you insight into some of those inner changes that we need to make in order to have an actually different experience in the next chapter that we want to create. What are some of those themes?
也不会消除关于你日常生活应该有什么感觉的不切实际的期望。所以我觉得这是我们关于迈向下一篇章的第一个共同建议。好吧，甚至还要加上一点：在想要开启新篇章的内在探索中，写写日记，或者跟咨询师、教练聊聊，探讨一下我的主题是什么。在到目前为止经历的这所有不同篇章中，我有哪些模式和重复的经历？因为这能让你深入了解我们需要做出哪些内在改变，以便在我们想要创造的下一个篇章中获得真正不同的体验。这些主题有哪些呢？
Because I'm trying to think of some in my own life and I'm getting stuck. Yeah. Okay. Well, I mean, themes could include feeling persistently dissatisfied in relationships and having this grass is greener thing going on. you know, no matter who you're with. And so the patterns would be ending relationships with perfectly nice people because you don't feel the chemistry or you're not having like this next level experience
因为我正试图在自己的生活中想出一些来，却卡壳了。好吧。主题可能包括：在恋爱关系中持续感到不满意，无论和谁在一起都有这种“草色遥看近却无”（总觉得别人的更好）的心态。
that you think that you're going to have. Changing jobs or moving. Like I think when you've cycled through what you were talking about, like moving to Sydney and like I made all these changes and why do I still feel the same way, you know? That can help give insight into what's really going on. Let's see, what would be examples of other themes? You know, the day-to-day things that stress you out, like you're kind of, how do I usually feel on the inside?
所以模式就会是：因为你觉得没有那种化学反应，或者没有那种你以为自己会有的高阶体验，于是便结束了与那些完全不错的人的关系。频繁换工作或搬家。我觉得当你经历过你刚才谈到的那些循环时，比如搬到悉尼，然后想：“我做了所有这些改变，为什么我的感觉还是和以前一样？”你知道的，这有助于让我们深入了解到底发生了什么。让我想想，还有什么其他的主题例子？你知道的，那些让你感到压力的日常生活琐事，比如你通常在内心深处感觉如何。
If you can quantify those and articulate them, that helps you understand what the next chapter could really involve. It would be a substantial change. So like an example in my own life, as you may have inferred from the previous story about not being able to find the debit card and the laundry still isn't put away. So I am a lifelong individual who has an ADHD. I didn't know that when I was younger. In my 20s, I had no idea that that's part of what was going on for me.
如果你能把这些量化并表达出来，它就能帮助你理解下一个篇章真正可能包含的内容。那将是一个实质性的改变。比如我生活中的一个例子，正如你从之前那个找不到借记卡、衣服还没收起来的故事中所推断出的那样——我是一个终身患有注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）的人。我年轻时并不知道这一点。在我二十多岁的时候，我完全不知道这就是我身上发生的一部分情况。
And it was in my 30s, actually, like finally connecting those dots. But I had to go through a period of time where all of these different chapters of my life, the common theme was feeling disorganized, feeling kind of chaotic, feeling like, you know, not really showing up in the way that I wanted to. And so it was really funny, okay, what's the common theme here? It wasn't, it wasn't the environment. What's happening in terms of my practices and ways of being that's contributing to me having these experiences over and over and over again? And obviously, still a work in progress, but like being able to identify the kinds of systems or practices that can help us be more of what we want to be and how feel more of how we want to feel
实际上是在我三十多岁时，才终于把这些点连了起来。但我不得不经历这样一段时期：在我生活的这所有不同篇章中，共同的主题是感到杂乱无章、感到某种混乱、觉得自己没有以自己想要的方式展现出来。所以当时很有趣，我就想：“这里的共同主题是什么？”这不是环境的问题。在我的习惯和行事方式中，究竟发生了什么，导致我一次又一次、一遍又一遍地经历这些？显然，这依然是一个正在进行中的过程，但能够识别出那些能帮助我们更多地成为我们想成为的人、以及如何更多地感受到我们想感受的那种状态的系统或实践，
is really the long-term solution when it comes to designing that new chapter that's based on the outcomes you want to have. That makes so much sense. I also feel like I'm really sitting here being like, oh, I need to probably identify my themes because that one of moving is incredibly relevant to me. Like, I always get this. I feel like it's interesting. I came into this really wanting to talk to you about this, you know, starting this new
当设计那个基于你想要结果的新篇章时，这才是长期的解决方案。这太有道理了。我也觉得自己现在坐在这里想：“哦，我大概需要找出我的主题了，”因为搬家那个主题跟我太有关联了。我总是遇到这种情况。我觉得很有意思，我来这儿时真的很想跟你聊聊这个，你知道的，关于开始人生新篇章的话题，因为我想：“哦，我在考虑搬家。”然后你问：“主题是什么？”我就想：“啊，每次我开始感到有点停滞或无聊时，我立刻就会想：‘你知道什么能让我感觉好点吗？搬家。’”搬家。我觉得，没有什么比搬家更让人兴奋、更具挑战性的了。这就像是，当你试图结交新朋友时，生活怎么会无聊呢？
chapter in life because I was like, oh, I'm considering moving. And then you said, what are the themes? And I was like, ah, every time I start to feel a little bit stagnant or bored, I immediately am like, you know what's going to make me feel better? A move. A move. I'm like, because nothing is more exciting in life, more of a challenge than a move. It's like, how can life be boring when you're trying to make new friends?
当你探索一个完全新颖的环境，当你建立新生活、装饰新家时，所有这些都是。所以，我真的在往后靠并仔细思考。不过在某些情况下，我确实认为我们需要承担这样的风险。有些时刻，你可能会觉得，你的外部生活确实有某些不对劲的地方，对吧？可能是你正在从事一份让你感到深深空虚的工作或职业，而你一直有一种感觉：我想做更多的事情，我想做不同的事情，也许我想做一些更有创造性的事情。我们该如何看待这一点，以分清这确实是我们想做的事，还是我们
When you're discovering a completely novel environment, when you're building a new life, decorating a new home, like all of those things. And so I've really, I'm sitting back and thinking about it. In some cases, though, I do think that we do need to take risks. like that. Like there are moments where it's like it might actually be that there is something in your external life that is not right for you, right? It might, it might be that you are working a job or in a career that is deeply unfulfilling and you've always had this sense of I want to do something more, I want to do something different, maybe I want to do something more creative. How do we approach that to know that that is actually what we want to do versus what we
觉得这样能让自己更快乐？我觉得我们在这种意义上对待风险的方式是——我总是提倡承担风险，不是指从桥上跳下去或别的什么，而是指承担风险的含义在于“做总比不做好，这能最大程度减少你未来的遗憾”。当我们考虑重大的生活变革时，情况总是如此吗？我会像一个真正的心理治疗师那样回答：这得看情况。绝对的。为了你的目标、你的价值观、你想要的生活而去承担风险，需要有信心和勇气。我完全赞同这一点。而且我认为，对我来说，没有比不做自己想做的事更大的遗憾了。特别是，
feel like will make us happier? I think that our approach to risks in that sense, I always promote risk-taking, not like jumping off a bridge or whatever, but like risk-taking in the sense that like it's better to do the thing than to not do the thing you'll minimise regret in the future. Is that always the case when we're thinking about big life-time? changes. I'll say this like a true therapist. It depends. Absolutely. I mean to have the confidence and the courage to take risks in service of, you know, your goals, your values, the life you want. I completely agree with that. And I think there, for me, from my perspective, no, no bigger regret than not doing something that you wanted to do. And especially, you know, talking with people sometimes at the end of
你知道的，有时与那些走到生命尽头的人交谈时，他们谈论的不是他们做过的事，而是他们没有做过的事。所以我认为这其中蕴含着很多智慧。不过我也认为你确实触及了一个重要的问题，那就是这个主题、这个模式：我如何知道我承担的风险是否会把我带到一个不同的地方，让我有不同的感觉，并最终让我感到更满足？还是说我只是把自己置于一个新的处境中？
their lives, that's what they talk about, aren't the things they did. It was the things that they didn't do. So I think there's a lot of wisdom in that. I also think that you really touched on something important, though, which is this theme, this pattern of how do I know if I'm taking a risk that is going to get me to a different place where I will feel differently and I'll finally feel more satisfied or whether or not I'm putting myself in a different place. You know, putting myself into a new situation with these false expectations that it's the circumstances that are going to change the way I feel. And so obviously, I don't want to start unpacking your stuff here on your podcast in front of all of your listeners. Well, questions I would, you know, encourage
把自己扔进一个新的局面里，却抱着一种虚幻的期望，以为是环境改变了我的感受。所以显然，我不想在这个播客当着你所有听众的面开始剖析你的私事。不过，我会鼓励每个人思考或写日记的问题是：如果我生活在不同的地方或从事不同的职业，我设想对我来说会有什么不同？请具体一点。你知道的，比如我的感受会是怎样的，为什么？当你问自己这些问题时，去想想：这是否与我的价值观或意义相连？为什么我要把它依附于这个特定的职业、关系或我可能要搬去的地方？
everybody to be thinking about or doing some journaling about is what do I imagine would be different for me if I lived in a different or a different career, for example, and be specific. You know, like how would I be feeling and why? And as you're asking yourself those questions, be thinking about, is this connected to my values or my meaning? And why am I attaching it to this specific career or relationship or location that I might be moving to. And the real power question is what would need to be different about the way I was
而真正有力量的问题是：如果我此时此刻就想有这种感觉，我在这里、现在展现自己的方式需要做出什么改变？开始去区分：我是不是在追逐一个虚假的想法，却错失了在原地生长的机会？我经常在那些转换职业的人身上看到这一点，对吧？他们决定了他们的工作、雇主或别的什么有些地方让他们感觉不舒服了，有时候确实如此，他们在别处有更好的机会，所以祝他们一切顺利，去吧。但当人们只是离开一份工作又跳进另一份工作，却没有真正在原地成长，也没有思考“到底是什么让我对工作感到如此压力山大”时，他们就无法发现：也许对他们来说，有效管理时间、设定界限或以有效的方式组织工作是很困难的。
showing up here and now if I wanted to feel this way, write this very second. To begin to differentiate, like, am I chasing a false idea and missing the opportunity for growing in place? I see this oftentimes in people who change careers, right? They've decided that there's something about their job or their employer or whatever that doesn't feel good for them anymore and sometimes legitimately that's true they have better opportunities elsewhere so godspeed go do that but when people just get out of one job and into another without really growing in place and thinking about what is actually going on with me that I'm feeling so stressed out about my job they don't get to uncover the fact that maybe it's difficult for them to manage their time effectively or set
但他们并不审视自己在工作中的运作方式，而是把问题归咎于工作本身。这样做的话，他们就失去了一个非常好的个人成长机会。我也觉得这其实也是对停滞感的一种恐惧，担心我是不是在做这件事上浪费了生命。我是不是在这份工作中浪费了生命？我是不是在这段关系中
boundaries or organize their work in a way to be effective. But they don't look at how they're operating in their job. They attach it to the job itself. And in doing so, lose a really great opportunity for personal growth. I also feel like it's this fear of a sense of stagnation as well, a fear of a sense of am I going to waste my life doing this thing? Am I going to waste my life in this job? Am I going to waste my life
浪费了生命？我是不是在这座城市、这些人身边浪费了生命？这种恐惧，我想这几乎是一种存在主义的焦虑：我们明白，而且我想我们作为一个集体也明白，根据你的信仰，我们真的只拥有一生。
in this relationship? Am I going to waste my life in this city around these people? And it's that fear of, I think it's almost like existential dread of being like I understand and I I guess we as a collective understand that we really only get one life
这就是我的信仰，你只有一生，你必须尽可能好地生活。而且我认为，有时由于过于害怕我们没有尽最大努力生活，反而会产生你刚才所说的行为模式，这可能是自我妨碍的一种形式，对吧？实际上是在削弱我们对真实目的、真实愿景、对真正自我的真正奉献，因为我们在追求一个由恐惧创造出来的不同版本的自己——比如害怕做得不够、害怕错过什么的恐惧。我们如何在其中找到平衡？像“进行一次独家旅行是我人生规划的一部分”这样的冒险，如何在其中保持平衡？
based on your beliefs. That's what I believe you get one life, you have to live it as best as you can. And I think sometimes being so fearful that we're not living in as best as we can actually creates patterns of behavior, as you were saying, that may be a form of self-sabotage, right? Actually undermining our true sense of purpose, our true vision, our true dedication to our actual selves, because we're pursuing a different version of us that has been created by fear, like a fear of not doing enough, a fear of missing out. How do we approach that with balance? The balance of like, yes, taking risks is part of how I see my life. For example, like going and doing a bunch of solo travel is something that I see is
基于你的信仰。我相信人只有一生，你必须尽力去过好它。而且我认为，有时过于恐惧以至于我们没有过好当下，实际上会像你刚才所说的那样，导致一些行为模式，这可能是一种自我破坏的形式，对吧？实际上是在削弱我们真正的目标感、真正的愿景、我们对自己真正的奉献，因为我们在追求一个由恐惧创造出来的、不同版本的自己，比如害怕做得不够，害怕错过。我们如何以平衡的方式来对待这一点？这种平衡就像是：是的，冒险是我对生活的理解的一部分。例如，去进行一系列独自旅行是我认为...
integral to my life. Hiking Everest is one of my biggest life goals or yes, I do. Yes, I do want to, you know, move to a new city where I know nobody. How can we manage both of those needs? The need to, firstly, have a stable sense of self and do that self-work of like, maybe this is internal, versus the need to also push beyond our comfort zone in ways that might leave us feeling perhaps more lost or might make us feel more content. Does that make sense? Do you understand this balance that I'm trying to really get to me? I do. I do. I think what you're saying is like almost how to know what to trust and like what is the path that would help you. And so I guess what what I would be thinking about is drilling down into the values that are defining your sense of what is important.
对我的人生至关重要。去珠峰远足是我人生中最大的目标之一，或者，是的，我是这么想的。是的，我的确想要搬到一个谁都不认识的新城市。我们该如何兼顾这两种需求呢？一方面，我们需要有稳定的自我意识，去做那类自我探索的工作——也许这些是内在的；而另一方面，我们又需要以可能让我们感到更加迷失、或者也可能让我们感到更满足的方式，去跨越舒适区。这说得通吗？你理解我真正想要表达的这种平衡吗？我理解。我完全理解。我觉得你的意思几乎是，如何知道该信任什么，以及什么才是能帮助你的道路。所以我想我所考虑的是，深入挖掘那些决定你对“什么才是重要事物”看法的价值观。
Like you use this phrase, like, I don't want to waste my life. And so what would be happening if your life were wasted? And like to use your example, there was a value around, experiencing new things, like having adventures, novelty, right, like pushing your limits. Those are values. And so it's like what you're saying is that if I'm not expressing these values, that would mean that my life wasn't worth living, that I had wasted my life somehow. And so I think there's a lot of valuable exploration that comes from getting into what is valuable and meaningful to each of us as individuals. So like going back to the story that I started with,
就像你用了这样的词组，比如“我不想浪费我的人生”。那么，如果你的人生被浪费了，会发生什么呢？借用你的例子，当时有一种关于“体验新事物”的价值观，比如追求冒险、新鲜感，对吧，比如突破自己的极限。这些都是价值观。所以这就好比你在说，如果我没有表达出这些价值观，就意味着我的人生不值得过，我的人生在某种程度上被浪费了。因此，我认为，深入了解我们每个人各自看重和珍视的是什么，会带来许多有价值的探索。所以回到我最初讲的故事，
when I was in my 20s and this huge new chapter opened up for me, I had been working in jobs where I was just kind of there. It wasn't really attached to any personal meaning or any of my own life values. and I wasn't clear at that time about what those things were. And it was only after, you know, going through that crisis, right? And thinking about I could die at any second. My cousin Jimmy was in his office on the top of the World Trade Center, mining his own business, drinking a cup of coffee at 9 o'clock in the morning,
在我二十多岁、人生翻开崭新一页的时候，我曾做过一些只是“混日子”的工作。它们与任何个人意义或我自己的生活价值观都没有真正的联系。当时我并不清楚这些东西到底是什么。直到经历了那场危机之后，对吧？并且思考着我随时都可能会死。我的表弟吉米当时正在世贸中心顶层的办公室里，安分守己地喝着早晨九点钟的一杯咖啡，
and an airplane came through the window. And it just like took away the certainty that your life is just going to like go on forever. And so it pushed me into contact with this idea. of, you know, at the end of my life, looking back, what would have been made my life worth living? And part of that really was, I want to be of service to other people. Like if I could figure out a way to help other people grow or be helpful to them in some ways, and that could go in a lot of different directions in terms of a career path, but in order for me to feel like my life had been worth something, it would have been making a positive impact in the lives of other people.
然后一架飞机撞穿了玻璃。它就这样粉碎了“你的人生会永远这样继续下去”的确定性。于是，它把我推向了这样一个想法：在我生命的尽头回首往事时，是什么会让我的生命值得度过？其中一部分真正让我确信的是，我想要为他人服务。如果我能找到一种方法来帮助其他人成长，或者在某些方面对他们有所帮助——这在职业道路上可以有许多不同的方向，但为了让我觉得我的人生没有白过，那一定是对其他人的生活产生积极的影响。
But that's the kind of value exploration I'm talking about because when we can understand that, that's where you begin to feel confident about I'm making the right decision because you're comparing your life choices to the values that you've clarified for yourself. Does that make sense? Oh, my goodness, yes. Absolutely. That makes so much sense to me. And I think it's so interesting because.
但这就是我所说的价值观探索，因为当我们能够理解这一点时，你就会开始对“我正在做出正确的决定”感到自信，因为你正在将你的人生选择与你为自己厘清的价值观进行对比。这说得通吗？哦，天哪，是的。完全说得通。这对我来说太有道理了，而且我觉得非常有趣，因为
we're talking about, you know, starting the next chapter in your life. Right. And maybe like the next chapter is not that big life change that you feel you need to make. It's actually sitting down and that self-appraisal and that real deep dive into what do I actually want from my life? What are my values here? What is my vision? And I think what is genuinely going to make me happy and satisfied? in the long term rather than just as an instantaneous kind of blip on the radar,
我们在谈论的是，你知道，开启人生的下一篇章。对吧。也许所谓的“下一篇章”并不是那种你觉得非做不可的重大生活改变，而是静下心来进行自我评估，深入探究我到底从生活中想要什么？我这里的价值观是什么？我的愿景是什么？我认为从长远来看，什么才是真正能让我感到快乐和满足的东西，而不仅仅是雷达上的一道转瞬即逝的闪光，
like a little bit of an outlier. You know, like I think back to that example of people to leave relationships with people that they might deeply love just because they don't meet some vision for what they, for a fairytale romance, obviously that's totally your call. But I think it's interesting that that actually might leave us in a place where we are alone, even though our struggle has been to not be alone. So it's kind of counter to what we actually expected it to be the outcome. And also it counter to perhaps our vision and our value to find someone we love and settle down
就像是一个微小的异常值。你知道，就像我回想起那个例子：有些人离开他们深爱的人，仅仅因为对方不符合他们对童话般浪漫的某种愿景。当然，这完全取决于你个人的选择。但我觉得有趣的是，这实际上可能会让我们陷入孤独的境地，尽管我们一直在努力摆脱孤独。所以这在某种程度上与我们原本期望的结果背道而驰。这也可能违背了我们的愿景和价值观——即找到一个我们爱的人并安定下来，
and have them in our life. So I think that was excellent advice. And I feel like perhaps different than what people expected. I know. But that's the thing. I think when you get clear about your values, it then becomes easy to make decisions on a day-to-day basis because all you have to do is compare a course of action. Is this an alignment with my values or not?
让他们留在我们的生命中。所以我认为这是一个极好的建议。而且我觉得这可能与人们的预期有所不同。我懂。但这就是关键所在。我认为，当你厘清了自己的价值观后，日常做决定就会变得轻而易举，因为你所需要做的只是去比对某种行动方案：这是否符合我的价值观？
Another piece of this to try to get that clarity around going into a next chapter, taking a risk and being reasonably confident that it's the right risk. So for example, me, going back to counseling school, tons of money, tons of time. I don't. didn't know if I was going to like it as a career, but having that values clarity helped me be like, I'm going to try this. I'm going to try this. And I'm glad I did. But the other thing to be aware of is that it's not just that we hold values. And so it could be adventure, being of service, family, unconditional love, financial security, spirituality, all of these. But it's also organizing these values in terms of importance because somebody whose value of financial security is a higher
这是为了获得这种清晰感而需要做的另一项工作——去迎接人生的下一篇章、承担风险，并有合理的把握确信这是一个正确的风险。比如我当年重返咨询学校，花了大笔金钱和时间。我不知道自己是否会喜欢把它当成职业，但这种价值观的清晰度帮助我下定决心：“我要试一试。我要去尝试。”我很庆幸自己这样做了。但另一件需要意识到的是，我们持有的不仅仅是某一种价值观。这些价值观可能是冒险、奉献、家庭、无条件之爱、财务安全、灵感等等。但同样重要的是，要根据重要性对这些价值观进行排序，因为对于那些将“财务安全”视为比“慷慨大方”或“追求冒险”更高级别
priority value than being generous or having adventures, their life is going to look very different because they're going to be making choices that prioritizes one value over another. So that's where, you know, a lot of introspection and self-clairity becomes very important when you're thinking about designing a new chapter. Yeah, understanding what you're actually motivated by as well, I think. Correct. That's exactly it. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts,
优先价值的人来说，他们的人生将会截然不同，因为他们会做出将某种价值观置于另一种价值观之上的选择。因此，当你考虑规划新篇章时，大量的内省和自我清晰度就变得非常重要了。是的，我认为同时也要理解真正驱动你的是什么。没错。完全如此。百分之二。这就是当电梯也可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中的心理韧性、体能训练以及韧性培养的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家进行对话，
and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Cent on the I-Hard. radio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
还有更多嘉宾，一同看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油天生会引发炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。节目名称是“T-W-O-P-Cent”，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
或者坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克兰蒙特·希尔的节目，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
大谈80年代的快克毒品。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时都能聊一整天快克，但只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，说到这儿，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
我不认为对黑人群体来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人群体而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师吉尔·盖恩斯。值此心理健康意识月之际，我将带上我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing, and we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入这场追逐，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是说你做个好人只是因为你感到害怕？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两种不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and personal. on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed
我希望你们能真正做一个好人。加入我，吉尔·盖恩斯，我们将就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和个人话题展开真实的对话。就在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中。打开你的免费iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会
revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
暴露出她说法中前后矛盾的明显破绽。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战，只为证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天呐，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I feel like you've created a lot of self-interrespection for me and things for me to go away with. I hope that there are others who are listening to this who were perhaps contemplating ending a relationship, starting a new career, quitting a job that they once thought was their dream job, who are better able to sit back and be like, is this new life chapter really what I think it is?
女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被正式指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事绝不会结束。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。所以我觉得你为我引发了许多内省，也留给了我很多可以带回去思考的东西。我希望其他收听节目的听众中，也有人可能正在考虑结束一段感情、开始一段全新的职业生涯、或是辞去他们曾经认为是梦想的工作，但现在能更好地静下心来思考：这新的人生篇章真的是我想象的那样吗？
Or is it kind of a proxy for not wanting to change something internally that's going to leave me to satisfy no matter where I am? So I want to thank you so much for coming on to the show and for joining us. Oh, well, thank you again for inviting me. This is a great conversation. And I do hope that this conversation was helpful for your listeners and starting to get clarity and confidence to know what the next chapter involves. Is it changing circumstances, doing some personal growth work that changes their own inner landscape,
还是说，这只是不想改变内心某些事物的借口，无论我身在何处都无法让我感到满意？所以我要非常感谢你来到节目中并做客。哦，也谢谢你再次邀请我。这是一次非常棒的对话。我也希望这次对话能对你的听众有所帮助，让他们开始获得清晰感和信心，去了解下一篇章究竟意味着什么。是改变环境，还是做一些能够改变他们内心世界的个人成长工作？
but the real value is getting clear on our meaning, our values, our purpose, and then making decisions that are based on that. Absolutely. I feel like that is such a valuable insight. valuable advice. So thank you so much for sharing it. Like it was, yeah, it was a, it was a beautiful episode. So thank you for coming on. Where can people find you? Obviously, we've spoken about your own podcast if they want to listen to more love happiness and success. Do you have an Instagram? Do you have anywhere they can follow along with your journey and
但真正的价值在于明确我们的意义、价值观、目标，然后基于这些做出决定。绝对是。我觉得这是一个非常宝贵的见解，宝贵的建议。所以非常感谢你的分享。这真的是，是的，这是一期非常美好的节目，谢谢你做客。人们在哪里可以找到你呢？显然我们已经谈过你的播客了，如果他们想听更多关于《Love Happiness and Success》的内容。你有Instagram吗？有什么地方可以让他们关注你的旅程以及
what you're working on? Oh, thank you for asking. Yes, love happiness and success podcast. Welcome to Listen. I recently started doing this video versions. They could come hang out in my office on YouTube for the Love Happiness and Success podcast. Also, yes, certainly do Instagram at Dr. Lisa Marie Bobby. But really on my website, Growingself.com. So there, another value and source of meaning for me is being able to write and put information out to the world. And so there is an extensive blog with all kinds of articles and podcast playlists that I put together for people.
你正在做的事情吗？哦，谢谢你的提问。是的，“Love Happiness and Success”播客。欢迎收听。我最近开始制作视频版本了，他们可以来YouTube上的《Love Happiness and Success》播客频道，在我的“办公室”里闲逛。另外，当然有Instagram，账号是@Dr.LisaMarieBobby。但最主要的还是我的网站，Growingself.com。在那里，我的另一个价值观和意义来源是能够写作并向世界传递信息。所以那里有一个内容丰富的博客，里面有我为人们整理的各种文章和播客播放列表。
And for your listeners, if they come to the blog and podcast page, I have everything organized into like content collections. So to come into the happiness collection. And then there's a little cluster of articles and podcasts around holistic life design that I think would be really helpful for people who are in this space. of where do I go? What decision do I make in terms of relationship or career that would be more information for them on this topic and all completely free. I just put it out into the world because one of my values is being of service. So there we are. Yeah, so generous. I'm actually going to go look at that holistic life design. I'll send you a link. Yes, please do. I feel like so many of us in our 20s need that. Like I'm sure there are so many people listening to this being like, I am so
对于你的听众来说，如果他们来到博客和播客页面，我会把所有内容都整理成类似的主题合集。比如进入幸福主题合集。然后那里会有一小批围绕“整体生活设计”的文章和播客，我认为对于那些正处于“我该去向何方？在人际关系或职业上我该做出什么决定？”这样迷茫状态的人来说会非常有帮助，上面会有关于这个话题的更多信息，而且全部完全免费。我只是把它分享到世界各地，因为我的价值观之一就是为他人服务。所以就是这样。是的，太慷慨了。我实际上打算去看看那个整体生活设计。我把链接发给你。好的，请务必发给我。我觉得我们二十多岁的人当中有太多人需要这个了。就像我确信有很多听众听到这里会觉得：我简直是
terribly absolutely lost. Some life design probably would really benefit me. So thank you for doing all of that for us, for people like me. I just want to say again, really appreciate you coming on board. If you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now and make sure that you are following for future episodes. If you also have a future episode suggestion or you just want to reach out, you just want to chat, You want to see what's going on behind the scenes. You can follow along at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram. And as always, we will be back next week with another episode.
迷茫得一塌糊涂。做一些生活设计可能真的对我有益。所以非常感谢你为我们、为像我这样的人做了这一切。我只想再次说，非常感激你能做客本期节目。如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何地方留下五星好评，并确保关注以获取未来的节目。如果你对未来的节目有任何建议，或者只是想联系我们、单纯聊聊天、看看幕后花絮，你可以在Instagram上关注@That Psychology Podcast。和往常一样，我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，状态怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人吉尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着西装，将自己全副武装。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这仅仅代表你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown.
2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控令人生下双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的天呐，太震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。2%。这就是当电梯也可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled,
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中的心理韧性、体能训练以及韧性培养的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、
healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands.
更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个多产的骗子时。她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这样逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。谢谢。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。